c'est vrai que c'est séduisant c'est
vrai que à priori c'est le discours de
la raison quand on l'écoutait
objectivement c'est vrai on est vraiment
d'ouverte encadré mais c'est vrai que
nous sommes en france nous sommes dans
un pays latin catholique de tradition
catholique où c'est vrai que l'argent au
relais je reviens à ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure sur sur l'argent c'est
7,7 cette manière de pointer du doigt
les plus tôt dans le discours les gens
qui sont jaloux l'envi en fait c'est
j'ai entendu pas mal de il ya des grands
patrons qui ont ce discours très souvent
qu'ils disent oui en france quelqu'un
comme bernard arnault regrette par
exemple qu'en france si on on le on
interpelle c'est pas obligatoirement
pour le féliciter comme aux états unis
un grand patron ou là c'est vrai qu'aux
états unis les grands patrons sont sont
félicités pour leur réussite il ya de ça
donc son discours est quand même
intéressant parce que si c'est le
discours de la réalité mais c'est un
discours à forte connotation
anglo-saxonne libéral et c'est vrai que
la france reste la france quoi est-ce
que ce qu'il fait il faut pas adapté ce
discours à la france être faire il a été
pédagogue clair mais c'est terrible à
dire mais ce qu'il faut pas être un
petit peu démagogue